president Trump addressing two major
issues today while meeting with the
president of South Korea including his
summit with North Korean leader Kim Jong
hoon we will get to his comments on that
in a moment but first the president is
commenting for the first time on camera
about an FBI informant communicating
with associates of his campaign a lot of
people are saying they had spies in my
campaign I hope there weren't frankly
but some man got paid based on what I
read in the newspapers and I think the
Department of Justice wants to get down
to it and I can tell you Congress does
if they had spies in my campaign during
my campaign for political purposes that
would be unprecedented in the history of
our country Senator Chuck Schumer is
saying these moves to learn more about
the FBI informant are an attempt to
obstruct the special counsels Russia
investigation while an investigation is
open and active demands for oversight
are tantamount to interference
especially when the folks demanding the
information are the most biased
irresponsible actors a man like Devin
Nunez who I hear privately from my
Republican colleagues they think he's
off the deep end all right I don't know
there's all sorts of stuff going on okay
so here's a question Kimberly yeah the
president has the power as the chief
executive officer the president the
United States commander in chief to
declassify all of these documents yes
would that just be a good idea you know
sit over with I'm so glad that was the
first question because I think it's it's
fascinating and there are a lot of
people calling for it saying you know
what let's just show complete
transparency declassify the documents
and put it all out there so there isn't
some of this leaking this and leaking
that putting bits and pieces out it will
actually show the whole framework and
exactly what happened and who did what
and maybe that's what the American
people need at this point instead of
like a drip from the faucet coming down
put it all out there and then well now
that's good what do you think Brian I
think you for that are you not for that
legal experts will say that that is a
huge mistake because there might be
somebody inside Russia that we're
dealing with right now that are helping
us today I would say this if you
doing a counter-terror operation why
don't you stop at the people why don't
you start with the people that are
actually trying to infiltrate the
Russians show some guts go over to
Russia and ask them what's going on or
use your coy contacts to find out what
they have to say instead you're going up
to these ancillary people on the Trump
campaign and nobody says they're major
players and trying to find out what
somebody might have whispered to them in
a drunken conversation and for people to
say like Chuck Schumer it's
irresponsible to allow these people to
find out who is who has infiltrated your
campaign that's because it's not your
campaign if someone infiltrated Chuck
Schumer's campaign they wouldn't say oh
wait a second the FBI is allowed to have
their sources
I don't blame President Trump for being
outraged to find out what was going on
in we're not going on with this
Cambridge Attorney excuse me the
Cambridge professor I don't blame them
for finding out Carter Page Clovis and
and Caputo what was happening with these
guys and the names that came out why
wouldn't he be curious about that it
would be illogical for him not to be the
only thing at stake is his presidency
and how long he stays well okay one let
me ask you then about the idea that if
the deeps state if we're calling it that
was so determined to hurt President
Trump what about the Democrats feeling
like they actually hurt Clinton more
because they kept the FBI investigation
into the Trump campaign under wraps but
were more forthcoming in the press about
Clinton well I mean I think that's you
know it kind of contradicts the whole
flow of what you're seeing now coming
from the president and conservative
media that the campaign that was hurt by
the FBI was the Clinton campaign there
was no damage done to president Trump's
campaign in fact I mean there's some
people who are arguing that because they
were conducting counterintelligence
operations as opposed to a criminal
investigation they were actually trying
to protect and try to act as a buffer to
keep the Russian influence out of all
the campaign including the Trump
campaign but I think what you're seeing
now in response to your question Dana is
an effort by the President and I think
it's unprecedented to sort of weaponize
an investigation into the investigation
into him but is it weaponizing Greg if
it's the Justice Department
saying okay look we have an inspector
general that everyone seems to support
Michael Horowitz because he's a fair guy
and he said that he'll take a look at
this at well as well so can we just let
that play out but it could be months
what is Russian for Mexican standoff
that's what we have right now standoffs
key
there you go spy versus spy look I
actually see what you would the question
that you just asked one I see the
opposite Hilary's investigation was put
in the press to help er it was to him
remember what Comey said yeah got to get
this out of the way because if she wins
and this comes out we look really bad so
let's help her Trump's was kept under
wraps because they wanted to catch him
right that was all that's why you see
that why is this one known and why is it
you can look at it anyway it's or
because I thought it wasn't going to win
yeah that's true but it is well you're
going back to the Laurel and the yani
which I will never give up the fact is
which collusion story now is more
persuasive all right so let's take the
yani
which is the Trump collusion story it's
been going on for 18 months we haven't
found a damn thing then you look at the
laurel of collusion FBI
Hillary Democrats the British spied the
in-form
one informant maybe two informants
inserted into the campaign if you
compare these two sides you've got one
where there was a meeting with a woman
about the Majin ski act that's something
like that right whoo that's
earth-shattering meanwhile you got a
dossier paid for by Hillary you got an
informant maybe two placed as a favor
you have the press playing it down you
have the dossier contents leat when you
start comparing these things one is
making a hell of a lot more sense as
collusion than the other I think you're
going down at what I would call the
rabbit hole because there's a lot of
anything's going down there well we've
been going down this rabbit hole now for
18 months forgive me if I find another
rabbit hole to go down Washington Post
in New York Times on Thursday they began
to leak out information maybe to get
ahead of a conclusions to let us know
that there's a rapid hole out there that
you're about to go down so let me give
you an idea what to the bottom here's
what I would say I think Alan Dershowitz
nailed it when he said I don't care if
it's the 98 Clinton investigation and
now the 2017 16 Clinton Trump campaign
you will never get to the bottom of it
as long as there's a
as a it is this type of operation we got
to go back to the 9/11 Commission to get
answers publish the results because it
did not affect the election you should
just find out what's wrong to stop the
next problem because this horse is out
of the barn and no one even saw the
horse oh I see I think there's a problem
here first of all this latest effort to
somehow say I hereby demand like he is
not president but he's some
authoritarian rule right here by the
manner the just the words not do that to
me
well what happened what happened Greg
immediately rod Rosa find the Deputy
Attorney General said okay I'm going to
do this in the question becomes is he
simply trying to appease the pressure
where you're you're is he following
orders obsessing over words nearby okay
so he sounds like King Arthur's castle
it sure does it sounds like a game not
the president the United States because
you are normalizing this kind of abuse
of power while the president is under a
special cause you defend another abuse
of power but I think everyone's missing
is not who's right or wrong it affected
the Trump is trying to run an election
he hires his foreign policy council that
he got on the back of a Cheerios box and
they go out and they do their thing and
somehow they they are targeted by this
Trump campaign the Russians are gonna
try to do this yes okay so they they
work they knew and then whatever the
people that were on the campaign we know
that they did have these contacts that
the Mickey Mouse whatever drunken things
but those weren't disclosed Kimberly so
then you have this question and I agreed
the Laurel and Yanni thing but I just I
don't understand if we ask that the
House Republicans are asking 12 House
Republicans are asking for a second
special girl if you want to make this so
much longer and 10 months on this issue
that would be a good way so but that's
still unfair because you're saying we'll
keep going with it keep going with this
other investigation and we'll keep
saying release all release all the
documents but tomorrow but you but you
should also say well if they think this
is just as important then it's just okay
so
Dana just to finish this so we concur on
that that they should just release all
the documents because I think then we're
gonna try it you know get another
special
council let's have the IG report come
out let's have the documents release
it's certainly within the power and
authority of the President of the United
States to do so so it's not like he's
trying to hide something saying let's
put it all out there and as it relates
to any people that we have operating in
the theater that could be compromised
you can redact their names and not like
you just turn it over there's nothing
there are protections in place this
legal expert is about